my  [Music]  children have been the worst impacted as  far as the lockdowns and you know  due to covet and now you know with with  poor air quality in terms of  their lifestyle having completely  changed  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  i think it's really a tragedy because if  you're outdoors you are you know  affected by hazardous air quality and  which is going to impact your certain  parts of your body and by not going  outdoors you are actually impacting  other parts of your body so it's like a  really catch-22 situation where you know  whether you like it or not health is  your health is being impacted  [Music]  [Music]  delhi's air quality is uh bad throughout  the year what we really need is a very  strategic and a very scientific approach  to equality management in delhi where we  track we look at air quality data  throughout the year but we also look at  strategic interventions throughout the  year  [Music]  you